[Music]
such a success breaking bad what's
interesting is I was one of those guys
and I think most people that work here
on the show we were watching it as it
happened but there's so many people who
taped it
yeah and or they're just catching up now
they've you know that they're buying it
now and they're watching it right and
you can see people enjoying it for the
first time even now yeah that the show's
been over for what nine months now yeah
yeah it's it's pretty cool I I keep
imagining that like kids in college you
know will discover it ten years from now
you know the way we used to go like to
see you know seventies movies and stuff
and you have nights where they get to
binge watch Breaking Bad so that'd be
very cool yeah it would be cool you know
what's interesting is the show is so
successful they've started making
Breaking Bad versions of Breaking Bad in
other countries are you aware of this I
heard something about that yeah yeah
yeah in Latin America or something yes
there's a Mexican version this is true
of Breaking Bad this is not a joke
there's a Mexican version of Breaking
Bad and this is the guy who plays you
yeah yeah I like the belt buckle yeah
there's also a German version check out
the German version yeah this is you in
Germany
[Applause]
and yes so he has to leave for long
periods of time I didn't know now you're
working on under the dome and you're
shooting it in Wilmington so you're on
this Shore I'm guessing this is in North
Carolina I'm guessing you do you enjoy
the water you guys it's beautiful
Wilmington North Carolina is beautiful
my family's out there we got a boat
I bought a boat for the summer mmm you
know just speedboat not it's not a big
bug just use Bowden it's great take the
kids to me and all that kind of stuff
my my wife decides to take it out for a
spin mm-hmm and go wrong there right
right so your wife is she said can I
just borrow the bike I would take it out
it's night you know is she to go out
fishing with my son so I'm like that's
cool yeah the only you have to do is not
hit another boat and and don't Beach it
right you know so about an hour later I
get a you know a text help stranded you
know so um that was not cool where did
she beat where did she put it she she
put her on a sandbar okay so so I called
the Coast Guard and they're like she
okay and like I said I think so you know
they're like well this you know the
title come in about six hours that's a
good Coast Guard that's a guy who hasn't
been married yeah I won't be for long
and you know you're married so you know
there's like there's there's a right way
to deal with that situation when you
talk to your wife and there's the wrong
way to deal with it you know I did the
wrong way unfortunately the right way is
to say honey I don't care what you did
to my new boat that I just bought the
port thing is are you okay that's yes
that's right well yeah you don't hear
the wrong way what did you say I'm just
curious yeah that's not good you can't
do that no no are you okay that's what's
important when I was first dating my
wife she borrowed my car and and
immediately backed it into a boat and
came in and I had passed I was visiting
my parents and I had passed out on a
couch and she woke me up and she said I
just backed your cut your new car into a
pose but I remembered my two halves of
my brain fighting and I was asleep and I
just was like the important thing is
you're okay
he was like I love you and then I went
in the path of Mike and you can
substitute anything right boat iPad
computer anything
you